so ptsd post-traumatic stress disorder
of people who don't know it's really
really difficult uh to treat and uh even
now so you know like a lot of the
studies show that like there's really
minimal uh effectiveness a lot of uh
overall sort of like mainstream
medications so ssris snris those types
of medications um
and a lot of my patients particularly
veteran patients were saying that they
were just getting a ton of relief with
cannabis
and so
you know when i looked
into it you know i find that a lot of
patients that are using thc at night and
a lot and doesn't always have to be thc
but thc at night can really help reduce
overall nightmares and that's what's
really you know one of the worst
symptoms of ptsd is having nightmares at
night and then not being able to sleep
and then you know as everyone knows
who's listening to this when you don't
sleep like everything just gets you know
so much worse so if you're depressed or
if you're anxious or even you have pain
doesn't even you know be need to be
related to mental health and you don't
sleep well often times like that just
just you know exacerbates everything and
makes everything worse
the next day so found the thc or
combination of cheap seeing cbd to be to
be helpful um for sleep for a lot of
patients and then cbd is really good in
the uh in the daytime
and uh the reason being too that that
it's so good for for ptsd patients is
there's one study and i know it is on on
rats but i've seen it in in humans as
well i mean we do need more randomized
control trials on it but um it showed
that it can actually decrease learned
fear and that's what you know ptsd is is
that it's learned fear you know so like
a lot of my patients they're afraid to
like go to the grocery store you know
just because like they just find it to
be so stressful and so overwhelming and
like oftentimes they get their food and
then they kind of just leave their their
food in the cart and they have to leave
because you just find it to be you know
so stressful and really overwhelming
it's like no one's like born afraid to
go to the grocery store that's obviously
something that's like a learned so um
you know through using cbd you know you
can actually decrease that learned fear
response and a lot of patients have
really really benefited from using cbd
in the day time to decrease that learn
fear response decrease or anxiety
decrease social anxiety just kind of get
back from uh to like you know better
overall functioning
interesting okay that's very interesting
um what kind of dose do you generally
recommend for people who are
experiencing let's start with the night
portion if you're trying to if you're
trying to improve your overall quality
of sleep what would you generally
recommend for people who are
experiencing nightmares
sure so um if you have nightmares
generally speaking you do need some thc
in order to get in order to get rid of
those nightmares um you know there are
some patients like say if you're totally
naive to canvas you've never used it
some patients can
get a good night's sleep by using just
cbd
but it's really the thc overall that
seems to improve um nightmares so if
you're you know just starting out using
um thc usually around five milligrams of
thc five milligrams of cbd is you know a
pretty decent dose um in order to in
order to uh start the treatment but
oftentimes that dose does need to be
increased
and i always get patients to use a
combination of thc and cbd
the reason being is because thc can be
really helpful for helping people fall
asleep but oftentimes they do wake up if
they don't have cbd on board and so um
it's good to have you know a combination
of both of those cabinets and now
there's actually another cannabinoid um
that's also commercially available kind
of called the cbn and cbd has also been
helpful uh to be to has been proven to
be helpful for sleep as well again we
don't have a ton of like like randomized
controlled trials on this right now
unfortunately but um you know just
through anadolu evans and you know if
you're seeing my patients you know i can
say that there's definitely an
efficacious effect by using cbn with
those other cannabinoids um as well so
hopefully that answered uh most your
question
yeah that's interesting i haven't heard
of cbn
do people who use this combination or
thc at night for a long period of time
do they end up having any withdrawal
symptoms if there's they stop so thc
absolutely can be associated with
withdrawal symptoms and that's why i try
to get patients to use a combination of
thc and cbd um instead of just using you
know pure
thc and
the reason being again is because cbd
can negate a lot of the negative effects
of the thc
and because of that generally people
find it to be you know much much easier
to say come off of a combination of thc
and cbd as opposed to
say just high thc so you do need to be
you know careful about it and but on
that note too you know there have been
some really good studies that show that
there's virtually no
um withdrawal effects like at all from
using fairly high doses of cbd for a
long period of time
and then coming off them uh completely
but you can't say the same thing about
about thc
okay so you have to be careful with that
to know yeah yeah that's good to know
but then for people who like i only
became aware of
withdrawal from i have no idea how i
really didn't know i only knew that pain
medication caused withdrawal i knew that
there was alcohol withdrawal i knew
heroin withdrawal which is like kind of
like pain medication withdrawal i had no
idea that there were withdrawals from
basically anything your body can get
acclimatized to which makes sense but
for some reason i'd been taught oh don't
worry if it's you know an ssri or an
antidepressant or even a sleeping pill
it's not like a problem
yeah anything that's like psychoactive
you know can cause some uh dependency
and um you know psychoactive like
sometimes that word um doesn't get used
appropriately because you know caffeine
is psychoactive like it makes a change
in your overall mental state right so
anything that's like psychoactive can um
can can induce you know some type of uh
you know addictive potential but we tend
to use the word psychoactive with
something that gets you like high
like you know thc um but in fact you
know cbd is in fact psychoactive because
it does change your overall state of
being
yeah so anything like that that's that's
like whack that really changes but
something like you know like vitamin d
or something like you know um you know b
vitamins like those things are not
psychoactive right so you're not going
to have a withdrawal effect of course
you shouldn't stop taking the vitamin ds
so important uh you know and it's good
to have high levels of b vitamins as
well um but they're not psychoactive
substances
as opposed to say like caffeine or thc
or cbd
okay cool that definitely makes sense
um speaking of okay well actually no
let's start with this first say you're
experiencing ptsd during the day like
you use the example
too worried about going into a grocery
store or getting food what kind of
treatment like cbd do you recommend for
those types of people yeah so again i
try to get patients to just use cbd in
the in the day the reason being again
because i'm trying to mitigate you know
dependency on on thc now some patients
if they're in like a really really bad
state
you know they may in fact need a little
bit of thc to get them through that uh
you know short period of time
but in terms of cbd um i usually start
off with about 10 to 20 milligrams for
for patients
and this usually has to be done two to
three times a day so the half-life is
you know kind of all over the place in
the literature but somewhere between
four to eight hours i find a lot of
patients find that it tends to wear off
somewhere between four to six hours
although you have other people who just
use it once a day and they find it to be
effective
so it really does you know depend upon
the overall individual but generally
speaking about 10 to 20 milligrams two
to three times a day seems to be you
know fairly effective for people for
reducing the overall symptoms but you
know some people need like 50 milligrams
you know some people need um you know
even more like closer to 200 you know a
couple times a day um so it's uh it's
something that
does vary
okay and do you think that's just
differences in brain chemistry the
difference is how they absorb it
differences in brain chemistry also to
just differences in the overall severity
of the of those
you know like some people um you know
you can have a little bit of ptsd or you
can have a lot of ptsd and people have a
lot of ptsd you know they're gonna need
a lot more medication than someone who
just has uh you know a little bit